my name is ryan and people usually know
me from my channel ryan's world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is ryan's world a youtube page that
has garnered over 29 million subscribers
and over 45 billion channel views since
launching in 2015.
hi mommy
when i did my first youtube video i was
three years
old and my channel at that time was
called ryan's toys review
my most popular video is when i was
outside on a bounce house and i was
looking for easter eggs
how many views did that video get 2
billion
at first we thought oh is somebody
pranking us on youtube why are we
getting so many views
yeah we genuinely questioned who's
watching
[Music]
ryan's world has been the highest
earning youtube channel for each of the
last three years
earning ryan and his parents 30 million
in income in 2020 alone
thanks to a combination of sponsorships
and ads
one great thing about youtube is that
you can film whenever and wherever
so it's really flexible you want to
create the environment it's safe
and trusting environment for kids so
they feel comfortable and have fun when
they film
it hasn't been entirely smooth for the
family in 2019 the kadju's main channel
was the subject of a complaint by the
group truth in advertising to the
federal trade commission
for failure to disclose promotional
content
a shift to off-platform deals
incorporating toys
and branded merchandise has helped
ryan's world maintain
forward momentum through youtube's ebbs
and flows
well our core principle is to entertain
the kids and ryan's world fans and
feel connected with them through
creating videos
merchandise products or our own video
games or
tv shows and at that same time
i really want to show kids that
education can be fun
yeah we call it edutainment it's a
combination with
education and entertainment
one year after we launched our channel
we decided to
start our own company and we started
hiring video editors producers
animators and voice actors streamlining
the workload
and minimizing violence participation
yeah we always make sure that ryan knows
that schoolwork comes first
we limit our filming time with ryan
within three to four hours a week
and that's really allowing us to
maintain his
childhood as a normal kid what do you
like to do for fun
when you're not doing videos i like to
rollerblade and play on my ipad and
talk to my friends while we can play
games
but ryan's persona both on and offline
will continue to be a family focus
in the near term when do you think
you'll keep
reviewing toys and making videos until
forever
when i'm 25 i fully develop my brain as
an adult
so after that maybe i can do something
else any idea what you'd want to do
surfing surfing sorry that was new
you know what you want to be when you
grow up like for a job a game developer
so i can show off my own games
we're really fortunate dear that's how
many kids around the world
resonate with ryan and you know maybe
ryan is the reason they can move forward
through their difficult days so just
knowing that
aspect makes us feel happy creating
content
thanks so much for watching for more
videos like this you can stream
bloomberg quick take for free 24 7 in
any of the places below get live news
coverage interviews deep dive shows and
documentaries on the stories that you
care about the most
and be sure to follow or subscribe to us
on twitter youtube
instagram and facebook